[Music]
McDonald is the world's second-biggest
fast food company available in 119
countries around the world for
McDonald's beer to greek mac each
country has its own unique spin on the
traditional mcdonald's items and they're
definitely worth a try
stick around to see which country
launched green burgers give this video a
thumbs up if you love mcdonald's and
don't forget to subscribe to our channel
now let's check out ten McDonald's menu
items you cannot buy in the US a black
burger let's start with the one and only
black burger that was a huge surprise to
just about anyone including the country
at first appeared in in October 2014
McDonald's Japan launched a black burger
to rival with Burger King's burger which
was launched just a month earlier as
part of their Halloween campaign it's
called the squid ink burger and it comes
with two patties regular sauce squid ink
sauce spicy cheese fried onions and two
buns dyed with squid ink
according to the taste test it tastes
almost better than regular McDonald's
burgers with an added flavor of the
squid ink sauce which isn't as bad as
you might think it is although we have
to say these black burgers don't look
appealing at all if you ever go to Japan
we recommend you don't actually look at
it when you eat it you can also find the
black burgers in McDonald's Korea these
are launched for a limited time in 2017
however they were so interesting we're
sure they'll return back on the menu
they're much much spicier than the
Japanese black burgers as they featured
the added spicy fermented cabbage can
you handle all that spice or would you
prefer the Japanese version here's a
mind-blowing fact you might not have
known about McDonald's the restaurants
received sixty-two million customers per
day which is more than the entire
population of Great Britain hey guys we
are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup acts and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section we love to
hear from you Darrien McFlurry here's a
weird menu choice that is surprisingly
popular in Malaysia
if you've ever smelled durian fruit
before you probably remember its
distinctive smell forever
the truth is it's definitely not one of
the best smells in the world but it's
known as the king of the fruits in
Southeast Asia although smelly is
actually one of the most nutritious
fruits out there packed with plenty of
vitamins and other health benefits we
wonder if you're still able to smell the
durian when it's mixed with McDonald's
delicious McFlurry McDonald's Malaysia
launched the d24 durian McFlurry in 2017
it was a fermented addition product
which contained pieces of real durian
fruits and according to the news it was
hugely popular unfortunately you won't
be able to try the durian McFlurry until
next year
McDonald's Malaysia issued a statement
thanking their customers for showing
such enthusiasm in this unique product
as they didn't anticipate to sell out so
quickly they won't be able to restock
the fruit and tell 2018
speaking of McFlurry z-- if you love
McDonald's you're probably aware the
thermic Fleury machines never work all
that is about to change in 2017
McDonald's made an announcements that it
will start introducing the stores to new
soft-serve and milkshake machines across
Europe and the US that will work faster
and hopefully better here's two more
McFlurry
Malaysia we're definitely coming to try
the durian McFlurry in 2018 but bar em
during McFlurry is definitely not the
only thing you can find at McDonald's
Malaysia this breakfast item is one of
our favourites Berber am also known as
the chicken Tinga porridge is a
McDonald's breakfast staple and an
absolute must try for anyone who loves
porridge while this might be a totally
non-traditional menu item anywhere else
in the world chicken porridge is one of
the best breakfasts you can have in
malaysia this mcdonald's item comes in a
copper porridge mixed with chicken
ginger onion shallots and chili peppers
it might look simple but we promise
it'll pack a punch it's been noted that
the porridge you'll find in this dish is
actually pretty heavy with rice while a
regular version is much more layers
however it's still a delicious and very
we'll menu item you have to try it if
you ever visit McDonald's in Malaysia
the original recipe for Barbara Yama
seems to be full of taste as it calls
for a chicken breast eggs rice beans
garlic dry fried onions sweet soy sauce
and chili
however the McDonald's version is
perfect for anyone who's afraid of
trying out new food speaking of
McDonald's did you know the company
makes 27 billion in revenue and is
considered to be the 90th largest
economy in the world we wonder how much
of that is spent on the delicious Berber
I am McDonald's gazpacho if you know a
thing or two about gazpacho we bet you
can guess where this menu item comes
from as unusual as it sounds one of the
McDonald's menu items in Spain includes
an actual kiss Pacho soup it's a
perfectly refreshing soup for hot
Spanish summers that a slightly bizarre
choice to have in a fast-food restaurant
like McDonald's gazpacho is served
during the summer and it's made of cold
full flavored tomatoes onions peppers
and condiments that add to its delicious
taste to make it a perfect summer dish
it's recommended to be chilled for a
couple of hours before serving the
McDonald's version of the cold tomato
soup comes in small packets and it's a
perfect add-on to just about any meal if
you're feeling really adventurous we'd
even recommends if in the McDonald's
fries in gazpacho of course any Spaniard
can tell you that the traditional
gazpacho doesn't taste anything like the
McDonald's version as it includes fresh
ingredients and tons of finely chopped
vegetables however it's still a must try
McDonald's item win in Spain while
you're at it don't forget to try the ham
croquette which are also exclusive to
the Spanish stores here's another fun
facts about McDonald's did you know that
children often recognize the McDonald's
golden arches logo before they recognize
the cross make sure to watch our videos
on
images and psychological meanings behind
some of the world's famous logos
including McDonald's McDonald's New
Zealand Georgia pie it's time to head to
New Zealand which is not only the land
of the long white cloud but also the
land of secret McDonald's menu items we
never knew even existed
the Georgie pie also known as the steak
mince and cheese pie was first
introduced as a menu item in 2013 and
tested and 19 restaurants the item was
so popular it was reintroduced
nationwide just a year later the
McDonald's history with Georgie pie
dates back to 1996 when the fast food
chain brought all of 17 original Georgie
pie bakeries and its trademarks but
don't worry it's not all bad news
McDonald's hired the original Georgie
pie bakery owner to make sure that the
pie stay true to the traditional taste
and look and bring out the best flavour
of the beloved kiwi pies they're still
made to the original recipe which calls
for quality New Zealand beef and of
course they're stuffed with mince and
cheese
according to McDonald's the pies are
baked fresh in store each day and ready
to be devoured as a traditional menu
item we totally get the Georgie pie with
McDonald's hunger Buster menu which also
includes a quarter pounder medium fries
medium soft drink and a small sundae it
really is time to finally buy a ticket
to New Zealand
Georgie pies here we come speaking of
New Zealand McDonald's has seven hundred
and sixty one thousand employees
worldwide which is almost a fifth of the
population in New Zealand McDonald's
Hong Kong's pasta there are only three
McDonald's locations in the US that
allow you to try McDonald's Pizza butt
pasta like this is a McDonald's item you
can't even find in Italy McDonald's Hong
Kong offers a unique breakfast menu
we're absolutely dying to try it's a
bowl of mixed veggies a whole egg and
twisty pasta cooked in a hot chicken
broth for added flavor you can also
order the twisty pasta with sausage and
egg grilled chicken or ham and egg some
pasta choices also allow you to choose
from a chicken broth or tonkotsu ramen
broth either way it sounds completely
delicious and it's not even the only way
you can eat pasta at McDonald's in Hong
Kong in 2017 the company also introduced
mouth-watering bacon macaroni and cheese
toastie that is just as delicious
as it sounds alongside they also added
corn cheese and mushroom toasty both are
available as a breakfast item and are
exclusive to the Hong Kong restaurants
and let's not forget about the Hong
Kong's matcha tea or much--it layered
cake out of all menu items we've shown
you so far
McDonald's Hong Kong has to be our
favorite how would you order your pasta
we're thinking to go with the twisty
pasta with sausage an egg a bacon
macaroni and cheese toastie and some
matcha tea on the side did you know that
McDonald's is one of the largest
distributors of toys Hong Kong's
breakfast happy meals actually include a
mini version of the twisty pasta
McDonald's grease it's Greek mac do you
ever get tired of the usual burger buns
and which fast-food restaurants would
try out something different the Greek
mcdonald's decided to put a spin on the
traditional items staple the Big Mac and
changed it into something that would fit
their culture unlike the traditional
burger the Greek mac tom is in a pita
bun which is filled with pure beef
patties cooked with herbs a white yogurt
sauce fresh onions tomatoes and lettuce
it almost resembles a Greek hero while
still staying true to the typical
McDonald's look we have to say these
look totally delicious however you might
be surprised to learn that the Greek
mcdonald's doesn't offer a Greek salad
or any other special items that would
complement the Greek culture but then
again we're pretty sure most of us would
love to try the Greek mac we love the
name we love the look and we really love
the pita bread
speaking of grease did you know that you
can find the McDonald's on some of
Greece's most popular islands although
relatively small in size the charming
island of Crete the beautiful roads all
feature a McDonald's restaurant for
those who are looking to try out what
this fast food chain has to offer all
around the world we recommend eating
your Greek mac while taking in the
amazing sea views around you McDonald's
swedens chilli cheese top
here's another around the world menu
items that caught our eye
McDonald's Sweden might not have big
menu items like a unique burger or a
breakfast pasta but what it does have
are these absolutely delicious chili
cheese tops they're creamy on the inside
and crispy on the outside and that's all
we really need to know to fall in love
with them you can't really go wrong with
fried cheese and these are just a
perfect add-on to any menu to add to
their taste
and spice they also come filled with
jalapenos definitely not a choice for
those who don't like spicy food but if
you're anything like us
you'll love this menu item the real
question is is fried cheese a good
enough reason to travel to Sweden it
just might be
and although Sweden might have a royal
family the only mcdonald's that's
actually owned by a member of the royal
family belongs to the Queen of England
however the restaurant doesn't own any
royal themed menu items so Sweden is
still our favourite with their chili
cheese tops these would go with just
about any menu item but we're also
pretty sure we could easily eat several
boxes on their own what do you think is
it time to book a trip around the world
and try these delicious menu items for
we think so McDonald's beer if there's
one international menu item that's
always a topic of discussion in America
it's a McDonald's beer
it might seem completely bizarre to even
think about ordering beer in McDonald's
but some European countries like Greece
Portugal and France can tell you that it
definitely works and the beers not even
that bad if you have a friend that
frequently travels they've probably
raved about McDonald's beer and we bet
you didn't believe them the first time
but it's true you can actually buy a
beer at McDonald's and it's still a
mind-blowing fact although it's not a
popular item curious tourists definitely
love to try this crazy item if you want
your local McDonald's to start spilling
beer in your country you have to let
them know in an official response on
their UK website they have noted that
there hasn't been much demand for the
item to reach the UK market
speaking of Europe you'd never guess
which country has the most McDonald's
stores and 2016 its Germany with one
thousand four hundred and seventy stores
all of which also feature McDonald's
beer next is France with 1419 stores and
then
the United Kingdom with 1274 it's also
been reported that the country with the
lowest amount of stores and
unfortunately no McDonald's beer was
Bosnia with only three restaurants open
would you travel to Europe to try
McDonald's beer green burger you might
be wondering what's the deal with
McDonald's green burgers you probably
saw circling around the internet at some
point it turns out that in Asia
McDonald's loves to experiment with new
books and flavors including this green
burger which was once available in China
it was introduced as a themed burger in
2016 as a part of the Angry Birds movie
campaign the burger is a tribute to
Angry Birds bad piggies that get knocked
down by the birds in the game don't
worry the green part is just a regular
food dye they were called the naughty
green pork burger and as you might have
guessed they feature a pork patty and
egg a mysterious sauce with a hint of
jalapenos and of course the green buns
China also got the same themed red
burger which was basically the same but
with red buns
unfortunately these burgers are no
longer available but we are sure it's
not the last time McDonald's China will
feature coloured burgers did you know
that China was also one of the first
countries to launch a 30-minute delivery
service that operated in 42 restaurants
and was able to bring McDonald's meals
to half of the city's population since
then McDonald's delivery expanded to
Europe as well as the USA and it's still
growing
speaking of coloured burgers have you
ever seen KFC China's pink burger it's
amazing that's it for the ten McDonald's
menu items you cannot buy in the USA for
more videos like this one check out 10
foods you'll never buy again after
knowing how they are made see you next
time
[Music]